la russie championne as you tube de
blocage et exige la levée des
restrictions
le site de vidéos de l'américain google
a suspendu hier deux comptes allemands
de la chaîne arte il aurait prétendument
violé les règles de la plateforme en
diffusant de fausses informations sur le
corona virus puis en ayant voulu
contourner une suspension de
téléchargement la correspondance depuis
moscou d'antoine clairoix dès hier soir
la rédactrice en chef monde de rt
margarita simonet n'a réagi sur
télégramme qualifiant ce blocage de
véritable déclaration de guerre
médiatique de la part de l'état allemand
elle a dit s'attendre à ce que en retour
moscou interdisent la diffusion de
médias allemand sur le territoire russe
entre temps le gouvernement allemand a
lui aussi réagi l'a fait savoir qu'il
n'avait rien à voir avec la fermeture de
ces deux chaînes et qu'il y aurait des
représailles si des médias allemands
venaient à être interdite en russie le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
qui a publié un communiqué ce mercredi
matin estime quoi qu'il en soit qu'il
s'agit là d'une atteinte à la liberté
d'information et la liberté d'expression
écoutez le but de cette agression contre
les projets du holding médiatique russe
est évident étouffer les sources
d'information qui ne rentrent pas dans
le contexte médiatique que les
responsables allemands considèrent comme
confortable comme sur d'autres sujets
par exemple l'expulsion de diplomates ou
encore la position de contre sanctions
la diplomatie russe se prononce pour des
mesures de rétorsion symétrique compte
tenu de la nature de ce qui s'est passé
et qui s'inscrit tout à fait dans la
logique de la guerre de l'information
déclenchée contre la russie la prise de
mesures de rétorsion symétrique contre
les médias allemands en russie qui par
ailleurs se sont vus à plusieurs
reprises accusé d'ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures de notre pays
semble non seulement appropriée mais
nécessaire alors de façon plus concrète
le régulateur russe des médias pourrait
ralentir voire complètement interdire la
plateforme de partage de vidéos youtube
sur l'internet russe regardez
conformément à la loi fédérale du 30
décembre 2020 numéro 4 182 fz1 le
procureur général ou ses adjoints en
accord avec le ministère des affaires
étrangères de la fédération de russie
peuvent pour de telles actions
reconnaître une ressource internet comme
étant impliqués dans des violations des
droits et des libertés fondamentales de
l'homme l'inclure dans la liste
correspondante et ladite source peut
recevoir un avertissement de rose comme
nador dans le cas où le propriétaire de
la ressource ne se conforme pas à
l'avertissement de roscommon à tort la
législation prévoit des mesures de
restriction totale ou partielle d'accès
comme on vient de le voir les et
intérêts les autorités russes cherchent
encore réfléchissent encore à la façon
de répondre à ce qu'elle qualifie de
nouvelle étape dans la guerre
informationnelle qui est menée contre la
russie cette réponse pourrait aller
jusqu'à des blocages à des restrictions
de l'accès à internet donne l'accès à
youtube et où des médias allemands ce
qui pourrait avoir des conséquences sur
les relations entre berlin et moscou